welcome to google developers weekly for
November 25th 2013 I'm Louis gray and
this is our highlight reel of what's
happening in the world of Google
developers on the set and off it was an
incredible week for developers here at
Google so let's get right to it and
we'll start with glass Timothy Jordan
never seen without his trademark hat
give us a sneak peek of the brand new
glass development kit the GDK lets us
glimp the future of cool apps on glass
also last week we hosted the chrome dev
summit an incredible two-day web
platform experience this event featured
an overwhelming 12-plus hours of
presentations on dart blink PageSpeed
pinochle and more if you missed anything
we have it archive for you and if that
wasn't enough Colt McAnlis teamed up
with the times open team from New York
Times to talk about tuning websites and
mobile apps for performance you have a
need for speed and so do your users and
we've all seen the headlines about
large-scale password leaks breno de
medeiros and Tim Bray who are not
excited about this trend talk about best
practices in raw survival on how to keep
your accounts and information safe and
drive in Gmail getting closer together
Steve basel highlights the new
integration of gmail attachments in
Drive and what this means for developers
in your drive apps but drive isn't the
only google app getting new features
Jonathan Simon walks us through how you
can set up and use a Google Cloud sequel
instance this event covers creating a
database and connecting to it setting up
PHP pages and much more if your app is
up in the clouds make sure you watch
this video we then welcome back youtuber
eek Island from New York as he tells us
where to go for all the latest
information on our Java API client
libraries whether you use maven or
Gradle ekai has your answers and we're
celebrating the half birthday of Google
Play games but you're getting the gift
Todd Kerpelman is giving everybody
updated stks so watch this event for all
the fun and every year at this time the
days get very short or very long
depending on where you live and Google
Code and gets going pre university
students can sign up for google code in
and work on real world open source
software projects learn a lot and even
win prizes including a trip to the
Googleplex check out the program site to
find out more also the Google Civic
information API got an important upgrade
for us users this week now you can write
apps that connect users to their local
elected government all the way down to
municipal officials and our newest
chrome experiment a journey through
middle-earth launched this week it's an
interactive experience for Hobbit
fans and for mobile web developers it's
a great demonstration of what's possible
on mobile devices using html5 and
technologies like the touch of NS API
Web Audio API and media queries and
speedy spdy is our experimental protocol
for making the web faster and is doing a
great job this week we publish results
showing that speedy has dramatically
reduced latency in Google's major web
applications and the speedy work
continues and to make sure you never
miss a thing speedy or slow from the
world of google developers subscribe to
the Google developers on youtube and
check out the gdl schedule at
developers.google.com/live I'm Louis
gray and I'll see you in the studio